now the United States and Sudan are to
exchange ambassadors for the first time
in 23 years Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo announced it on Twitter and it
comes at the same time as the Sudanese
prime minister abdallah ham Duke is on
his first official visit to Washington
as the transitional prime minister the
moves are the latest sign of a possible
warming of relations between these two
countries which began to improve after
the removal of former President Omar
al-bashir all right we can speak now to
what lead Madiba who's president of the
Sudan Policy Forum and there's a
governance and development expert
joining us from Doha and Waleed and what
would constitute a successful trip as
far as as mr. Honda is concerned what
does he need to bring back to Sudan I
believe he so far has succeeded to a
great extent because the restoration of
us relationships with Sudan is very
essential I think America can only
influence other nations by getting
engaged in good relationship with them
not by alienating itself however I think
there is some naivety on part of Hum Dil
government and some moral ambiguity and
part of the Americans I let me start
with the American side I I think America
is too putting too much emphasis on the
S STL the state is a sponsored terrorist
list and instead it should help the ham
Duke and his government co-heirs the
military officers to come out gradually
out of the equation of power because
America does have leverage over the
Sudanese army it can Co acid it can
persuaded to to become more democratic
and to help it restructure itself there
doesn't there hasn't been any indication
so far correct me if I'm wrong that
America is
paired to take that vital set vital for
Khartoum at least and that is to remove
it from the the list of state sponsors
of terrorism because that's what Sudan
needs in order to to open itself up to
investment
nobody will invest in Sudan whilst it's
on that list yeah I think that's a very
good remark on your part I think it's
it's now the role of Honduran Duke needs
to get engaged in genuine elite bargain
he needs to get involved in serious talk
with the the military officers
especially the so-called military
council or what used to be the military
council he needs to find out we did what
is it exactly that they need so that
they can come out out of this equation
of governance do they need immunity and
so that he can find his way of bringing
those accused of having committed crimes
in the periphery of Sudan to trial and
if he gives them immunity maybe they can
help him bring those criminals to
justice but without bringing those
criminals to justice mainly military and
security officers who have committed the
genocide in that war I don't think that
the Americans will take him seriously
but but also I mean conversely what he
also needs in order to get anything done
is to bring in investment I mean ham
Duke himself has been created by the
Financial Times as saying that his
country is bankrupt I mean how bad how
dire is the economic situation in Sudan
and can Sudan move forward to the next
stage without international finance III
think Sudan at this stage is morally a
bankrupt
not economically bankrupt Sudan is a
very resourceful nation but 80 percent
of the national GDP goes to the army so
without restructuring the army you can't
put your financial statement in order
but in order to convince the army to
restructure itself
they need some assurances especially the
top-ranking or officials I think Hamburg
is is is is wrong in the sense that he
thinks that Sudan's problem is primarily
economic it is primarily a political
problem so far no attempt has ever been
done by him himself or by his fellow
colleagues in the in the cabinet to to
handle the issue of the periphery and
crimes that have been committed again is
the Nuba Mountains and South Kordofan
and therefore what lead Madiba thank you
very much indeed thank you